si el príncipe andrés de inglaterra
acaba de llegar a un acuerdo económico
extrajudicial con virginia you free
quien le había demandado por abuso
sexual así lo acaba de informar a través
de un comunicado hace menos de una hora
el tribunal de manhattan que está
llevando este caso virginia giuffré
demandó al príncipe andrés por abuso
sexual en ese entramado de tráfico
sexual de menores del multimillonario
fallecido jeffrey amstel y el principio
andrés lo ha negado siempre pero ahora
van a poner fin a este proceso con este
acuerdo entre ambos según un comunicado
que han presentado a ambas partes van a
presentar una carta de desestimación del
caso en un periodo de 30 días y cuál va
a ser la cuantía de esa indemnización de
ese acuerdo económico es algo que se
desconoce que va a permanecer
confidencial aunque sí que se ha dicho
en ese comunicado que el príncipe andrés
donará a la fundación donará un dinero a
la fundación de virginia free en apoyo a
las víctimas por abuso sexual en este
comunicado los abogados del duque de
york también y cito textualmente que el
príncipe lamenta su asociación con el
fallecido multimillonario jeffrey
epstein y elogia la valentía de los
demandantes y su fuerza por denunciar
públicamente estos casos además ha dicho
que va a demostrar su arrepentimiento
apoyando a las víctimas y apoyando sus
derechos de todas estas víctimas de
tráfico y abuso sexual